[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a chinese action
thriller film called kung fu girl
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
shannon is a martial arts student living
in hong kong her father dany runs a
local restaurant during the day and
develops games at night shannon's mother
passed away a few years ago while
driving to an airport since her father
refused to drive her that day shannon
blames him for her mother's death the
relationship between the father and
daughter hasn't been the same ever since
shannon lives in her school's dorm and
hardly ever visits home she has a
rivalry with a guy from her class named
ricardo he and his group of friends
bully her frequently one day the bullies
are in shannon's father's restaurant
complaining about the food not being
spicy enough even after devouring it all
they refused to pay shannon retaliates
against them and forces them to pay up a
humiliated ricardo throws the money to
the floor and walks away shannon picks
it up and hands it to her father who is
in a mascot costume she also apologizes
to him for ricardo's rudeness the next
day at school ricardo takes his revenge
by making shannon's friend's brother
trip and drop his food shannon's friends
ask her to forget it but she doesn't
want to let them off the hook she sits
with the group of bullies confidently
and eats from their plates an
intimidated ricardo leaves her alone and
walks away with his friends later
shannon finds out that he destroyed her
clothes in the dryer the group troubles
her every day laughing when she messes
up making her fall several times and
even adding frogs in her lunchbox a
local shop owner hosts fighting machines
in front of his house daily shannon is
informed that ricardo has defeated
everyone he has fought against until now
she takes the opportunity to challenge
him in front of everyone she even goes
as far as to bet him to wear a skirt if
he loses ricardo in turn asks her to cut
her hair and wear men's clothes if he
wins the fight starts and goes on for
quite a while however it is evident that
ricardo is way more skilled than shannon
suddenly he catches her off guard and
punches her in the stomach the pain
almost causes shannon to pass out after
the punch she can hardly get up and is
defeated in a single kick ricardo laughs
at her and hands her a pair of scissors
accepting her defeat shannon cuts her
hair the next day she goes to school
with short hair and is made fun of by
everyone when she enters the class
ricardo calls her a man making her
angrier than she already is when he
doesn't stop calling her names she
attacks him in the middle of the class
they have to be separated by the teacher
before a fight breaks out shannon is
then taken to the principal's office he
calls danny to tell him about his
daughter's shenanigans danny apologizes
for the inconvenience claiming that she
is aggressive because he hasn't been a
good father to her he also begs the
principal to let her free this time when
shannon goes to pick up lunch from the
cafeteria that day some girls block her
they have also joined hands with ricardo
to trouble her around the school
shannon's friend yells at everyone for
supporting a bully but they ignore her
not wanting to cause a scene shannon
walks away without her lunch she
reminisces about her mother who was the
reason she took interest in kung fu
while most mothers dressed their
daughters in princess dresses shannon's
mother made her train from a very young
age she believed that kung fu needed
girls like shannon as much as shannon
needed kung fu that night danny calls
her and asks her to come home for the
weekend since she hasn't been home in 3
months shannon is reluctant but she
agrees to visit him anyway after the
call with his daughter dany also calls
an investor and asks him to come over to
test his new game he has created a
virtual game where one has to fight in
reality to win at night shannon goes
home and meets her father dany tries to
indulge her in a conversation but she is
dismissive and rude when called out for
being impolite she forces a laugh and
ignores him dany also asks her about her
hair but shannon dismisses it and
doesn't tell him about being bullied
when he brings up the change in her
behavior after her mother's death she
blames him for all of it hurt by her
words dany walks away moments later
shannon goes to his home office and
snoops around she notices a strange
necklace on the table but she doesn't
think much of it she also finds a
headset on his workstation and decides
to wear it as soon as she puts it on she
enters the virtual world of ancient
china all of a sudden a group of people
attack her but she defends herself
efficiently she also notices that her
hair is back to being long then her eyes
land on ricardo who is dressed in
traditional chinese clothing and is
fighting the opponents it turns out that
the people he is fighting are robbers
trying to rob food from a farmer's house
shannon is surprised that ricardo is
doing a good thing for once then the
leader of the group norman comes forward
to fight ricardo however he is proven to
be weak against ricardo's expertise and
is knocked out within minutes after the
thugs run away ricardo gives the farmers
the sacks of grain that were taken away
from them shannon follows him and asks
him how he got into the game she soon
finds out that he is part of the game
with a different name and an entirely
different personality than ricardo he
also informs her of the powerful robber
brothers norman and tyson they have
gathered and trained an army to rob food
and supplies from the poor hence ricardo
is protecting the people of his town
with his life he is sure that since
norman was just defeated his
short-tempered brother tyson will come
to take revenge somewhere else in the
robbers camp tyson is furious he sends
some of his people to keep an eye on
ricardo looking for the best time to
strike the village then shannon is shown
around the village and introduced to the
martial arts academy she meets her bully
daryl who is one of the good guys in the
virtual world her school's principal is
the martial arts teacher he assumes that
she is with the robbers and makes his
pupils surround her on finding out that
she is just an innocent foreigner he
apologizes and sends her to her personal
room for her stay in the village shannon
is also introduced to the leader of the
village suddenly ricardo gets sick and
falls unconscious the group rushes them
to the village's medic miss aries she is
trained in martial arts and is a great
warrior later when ricardo gets better
she and shannon explore the village they
come across an old shed and see a
gruesome looking person meditating aries
explains that the man is her father who
has been in the shed for a year it turns
out that her father bow used to be a
traveler who helped people and caught
robbers everywhere he went however after
aries mother's death he wished to stay
isolated from the world and hasn't come
out of the shed shannon stays in the
village for the next few days and learns
different martial arts techniques from
the village's head she and ricardo
practice together and learn many things
from each other soon the village runs
out of food because of the increase in
robberies the head of the village
reduces the daily three meals a day down
to only two the workers and the
civilians are distressed because soon
they might die of starvation hence at
night shannon ricardo daryl and aries go
to the robber's house to steal grains
daryl uses a tube and darts to knock the
guards unconscious then they break into
the storage room and get ready to pack
everything in however the alarm rings
alerting everyone in the house of their
arrival ares comes in front of the
enemies to save the others the rest of
the group has to reluctantly run away
without her the next morning shannon
asks the village head to save aries but
he refuses to do so because aries was
caught stealing which is against their
rule following that she goes to ask for
help from arie's father bow she tells
him everything about her mother's death
and how she blamed her father for it
shannon says that her father couldn't be
nicer to her and admits that she was at
fault for blaming him she is about to
lose hope when bow comes outside of the
shed determined to save his daughter the
group attacks the robber's base and
fights the guards before rescuing ares
the father and daughter reunite and
decide to go on a trip like they used to
shannon wants them to stay until the
robbers are fully gone but bao claims he
has faith that they can stop the robbers
after tyson finds out that his troops
were attacked he gets ready to invade
the village with his soldiers knowing
that he is about to do something like
that shannon ricardo and daryl
brainstorm ideas to stop him shannon
knows that there must be a way to defeat
the enemy since this is a game after all
then she remembers the necklace she saw
on her father's table that matched
exactly to the necklace that a soldier
was wearing she happily thanks her
father for the hint hours later tyson
along with his soldiers attacks the
village the village head and his pupils
battle them with all their might amidst
the battle shannon notices the necklace
and the man wearing it however while
trying to fight him she is killed and
brought back to reality shannon refuses
to lose and wears the headset again it
turns out that she has one more life
left which means she can continue the
game from where she was earlier this
time she beats the soldier and manages
to get his necklace on opening the
locket she finds her mother's picture
inside in only a second all of tyson's
soldiers disappear because shannon was
able to figure out the clue when only
tyson is left they overpower him and win
the battle following that we see shannon
and ricardo by the side of the river she
tells him that she misses her father and
asks him to send her home ricardo
promises to always remember her and
sends her back to reality when shannon
is finally back it has only been a few
hours since she started to play it turns
out that danny and a potential investor
had been watching her play all this time
shannon hugs her father apologizing for
being rude to him the investor is so
impressed with the game that he offers
to invest 10 million yuan in it next
week is a national level kung fu
competition both shannon and ricardo
have taken part in the competition and
have been selected in different
divisions they have to win four rounds
to reach the finals on the day of the
competition shannon looks around and is
sad that her father is not present still
she does her best and wins easily
against the real-life aries similarly
ricardo wins the next few rounds and
reaches the finals shannon goes against
a guy in the semi-final and after an
intense match she defeats him
now the rivals have to fight each other
in the finals the audience eagerly
watches as they get ready to fight
ricardo strikes the first attack but
shannon dodges it likewise ricardo also
dodges all of shannon's attacks the
first round ends without any one of them
getting a proper hit the referee blows
the whistle indicating the end of the
round but ricardo plays foul and attacks
shannon even after his score is deducted
but he doesn't back down in the next
round they seem to match in skills and
strength suddenly shannon kicks ricardo
in the back and makes him fall an
enraged ricardo breaks the rules again
and hits her on the back of the knee
shannon is in pain but she still gets up
ready for the next round this time he
kicks her on the back of her head
breaking yet another rule shannon is
almost knocked out but then she sees her
father in a crab costume cheering for
her from the audience with renewed
motivation she stands up to fight
ricardo she remembers the technique she
had learned with the virtual ricardo and
uses it on him it works smoothly and she
knocks him out to win the competition as
the crowd erupts in cheers she runs to
her father and hugs him in the last
scene she is back in school she makes
amends with ricardo who comments that
she deserved to win the last match
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching